the following contains Oilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys today I'm going to talk about big
spoilers that are coming from leaked
photos from season seven set accessory
and do brown ink these days but be ready
because intensive spoilers are coming
let's start with the leaked photos from
filming set accessory two days ago
filming began location accessory will
depict King's Landing in the upcoming
season some of the most famous location
accessories such as the plays of the
Santa Maria narrow cuesta della Campania
which will depict alleyway Plaza de la
Villette us which will debate Street
Tavern in the market and the article del
Sol at the top of plasm horror all of
these locations are decorated in
Lannister symbols and will depict parts
of King's Landing first of all all these
locations are connected and it was a
little bit confusing on how they are
going to film all the scenes at all of
these locations in such small amount of
time as soon as I've seen that all of
these locations are connected by the
streets and as soon as I've seen that
all those locations in which scenes will
be filmed on the streets I knew
immediately that all those locations are
going to depict something big a parade
maybe and I could only assume who it's
going to be but now it's confirmed by
leaked photos firstly filming starting
the Lannister banners adorning the walls
accessory experts were also coming
dressed as a typical citizens of King's
Landing summer dressed as Leinster
guardsmen gold cloaks and there were a
few men in black outfit which we assumed
were representing urinals man and they
were right at this moment it was pretty
clear that something big is happening a
few days ago in the ER Worman known as
el area in the show and Rosabelle orange
cellars known as stain also came in
seseri last time we've seen the sand
snakes murdering Princess Myrcella
Prince Doran his son here Prince
trystane after which they along with
Elena TRL decided to become new ally v
Daenerys as we all know from season 6
finale the sand snakes were sailing with
Daenerys Targaryen to Westeros along
with many others as a bowler sending
previous videos also supported by leaked
photos
Daenerys along with her two armies the
tracking horde and the on solids will
arrive at Dragonstone
in the first episode of season
seven well Danny's with her army
Dragonstone t1d are a great joy with
their Ironborn man supported by the same
snakes and their army are going to have
a fleet battle against Iran Greyjoy
however is my prediction supported by
the plot league few weeks ago word that
team Greyjoy has arrived at Dragonstone
and was later beaten up by the Ironborn
man because he ran after his sister Yara
and their ally at the sand snakes lost
the battle fleet in which few said snake
died while few of them are going to be
captured along with Yara this all came
true yesterday it's known if your own is
going to beat them because of his
experience in fleet battles or because
he builds so many ships and simply
outnumbered them as we can see from the
new leaked photos on the filming set of
Plaza de Santa Maria King given final
appearance season 7 set along with Yara
and the sand snakes it's not most likely
that urine will pledge his iron fleet to
Cersei in the upcoming season but in
return Cersei will have to marry him
similar deal as he had with Daenerys by
that time his siblings were faster as we
can see yara alaria and ting will be
captured after urine destroys their
fleet and will parade through the
streets of King's Landing from leaked
photos we can see your own Greyjoy on
his horse which is decked out in an
grade you're looking faceplate leading
Yara in changed through the streets full
of King's Landing citizens who are
welcoming their new hero euron greyjoy
Yara is not the only one that is going
to parade through the streets of King's
Landing
they're also captured Illyria sand and
her daughter tain by this parade
victorious urine will prove to everyone
else that he destroyed the near Salas
and accomplished his promise that he
gave Cersei as well which will obviously
be helping her to make her ring a little
longer
most likely supported with a marriage
deal also from leaked photos as you can
see they're missing a bar and Amelia
these to send snakes in our opinion also
supported by Lee plot are going to die
during the battle fleet against Iran in
this very moment there are not leaked
photos which could confirm the fate of
Yara Illyria and terrene after they
paraded through the street of King's
Landing but in our opinion with two sick
villains like you
circe we don't even want to imagine
what's going to happen to them on this
filming set director mark mild was also
spotted which make the scene happening
in either second or third episode these
are the huge spoilers from filming site
accessory and be sure there will be a
lot more now let's move on to burning
I've already told you a few weeks ago
that the most famous sitting Croatia is
coming back to the pact few parts of
King's Landing which couldn't be made in
Spain it has been already proven that
the game of Thrones is coming to film in
Dubrovnik and the coming of Lina had a
known as Cersei bjornsen known as the
mountain and Nikolaj coster-waldau known
as Jaime is not surprising for us before
Nikolaj coster-waldau aka Jaime
Lannister came on filming set a
Dubrovnik he was firstly in the capital
city of Croatia in Zagreb the news about
that spreaded on all Croatian news
because Nikolaidis post an Instagram in
which he has posted a photo of Zagreb
and in description he wrote quiz time
where am I
not relevant for it but almost no one
guess where he was but according to
creation news Nikolai was in Zagreb for
filming BBC serious McMurphy
let me repeat this from our previous
video even that Croatia wasn't on
filming location list for the filming
season 7 provided by HBO in July it
seems that some unique locations cannot
be duplicated filming in Dubrovnik has
already started yesterday in the last
three days
also not surprised by that as it was
known that this filming is going to
start in the middle of December and also
the filming in Croatia won't last long
because they only came to shoot a few
scenes of the only one location that
couldn't be made in Spain the main
reason of the shooting
coming back to Dubrovnik is because of
its unique city walls they're more
detailed because of the fortress called
bokor which is one of the most beautiful
functional fortification architecture
the fort is located on the southwestern
part of dubrovnik city walls bokor was
previously used as the key point in the
defense of pile gate this fortress was
used in 2nd and 3rd season particularly
visible in various conversation material
in which they discuss battle strategies
to defeat Stannis Baratheon's army by
looking the sea also from leaked photos
we can see Jeremy Podesta the guy who is
directing season 7 premiere and the
finale it's not that hard to guess that
these things will happen in season 7
premiere which will represent in our
opinion one of the first scenes of
Cersei and Jaime in the upcoming season
on the set in Dubrovnik the mountains
also spotted nothing surprising by that
as we know that he asserts his guardian
24 hours per day the last spoiler if we
can even call it spoiler is that the
King's Guard under their new queen is
going to have the brand new armor to us
it's pretty similar outfit which Circe
wore in season six finale but she was
looking towards the great Sept of Baelor
and while she was proclaimed as the new
queen of the Seven Kingdoms now let's
get back for a few moments in Spain
apparently John Bradley known as Samuel
Tarly arrived few days ago in Spain
which could mean that we'll see a little
of Old Town filming it streets accessory
since we don't think that salmon will be
in King's Landing we have orders said a
little bit about Samuel Tyrell in our
previous videos we're aware that his
knowledge could play a huge role in the
upcoming seasons but in our opinion
salmon's knowledge will get important in
season 8 more than in the upcoming
season there are some rumors about
Samuel curing jours race kale in the
upcoming season mostly based on the
photo in which we can see drugs Ryu
nation with Daenerys at Dragonstone so
don't take this theory too seriously all
we know for sure is the jury will
reunite with Dany in the upcoming season
but who will cure greyscale or will he
even cured since there's also theory
about Jorah coming back to Daenerys
those through her as long as he can
before it spreads too much but however
if not in season seven sabbaths
knowledge will have a huge role in the
last season which is mostly going to be
a battle between the humans and the
undead army we are sure that salmon will
find something useful while being at the
Citadel something that could help humans
to win the real war Samuel might find
out how to make clear and steal the form
of mal that all of them need in favour
to have a chance against the white
workers so yeah cemetery will in our
opinion the biggest part of season seven
spend time at the Citadel and will be
trying to find something that might save
all the humans to conclude this these
are only first leaked photos from these
new filming locations so you can expect
more of it in following days let me know
your opinion on teams running after they
lost the fleet battle do you think that
he should have stayed and fight beside
his sister or do you think that he has
chosen wisely do you think there is any
possibility of your escaping or being
saved by her brother team along with
their nares or do you think that her
fate is sealed and the last one is there
any hope for even one sand snake to
survive let us know your thoughts on all
of these leaked photos feel free to
write your ideas about their faith or
how they are going to be executed by
those two lunatic villains hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and see you next
[Music]
you